I was playing Diablo 4 the other day and
I was thinking oh it's such a waste of
time doing this and not streaming it
like should stream this on Twitch
exactly like twitch is dying like
YouTube game I guess okay cool I guess I
stream it on the main channel on the
second Channel and then I guess you know
might as well restream I ow it to like
all the other platforms cuz and I
suppose I can ask question from the
audience while it's happening suppose we
can record that chop it up into I just
I'm just going to sit here and play
Diablo 4 for a little bit it's okay it's
all good that like confusion around like
should this be productive is something
I've wrestled with entire life and still
wrestle with if I sit on the couch I'm
like sitting on the
couch what what could I be doing while
sitting on the couch okay I'll text
people I'll text you know uh people
about ideas I'll get feedback on ideas
or maybe I'll call my mom maybe I'll
it's like sitting in Stillness is one of
the most challenging things to do or
just even enjoying something for a
moment like I'll just read this book oh
but this book Maybe by reading this book
I'll know how to write a book okay
that's good that'll justify
it